Blood is a useful substance, not just for
our life, but for our way of thinking.
It's served as a convenient metaphor for
so many ideas, covering the extremes and even
the contradictions of our experiences.
It signifies life, but also accompanies death.
It unites those who share it, but in doing
so it divides others.
It runs hot, it runs cold.
Whatever it is we need to describe, blood is
there for us to project onto, flowing through us.
And yet under the microscope, blood doesn’t
seem that remarkable.
The colors may be vivid, but the cells are
so simple and similar to one another.
How is it that our complicated,
contradictory sense of self,
recorded in literature and painting and film…
how does all that come down to a fluid made
up largely of the simplest cell in our body—
a cell so singularly focused on its task of
carrying hemoglobin that it actively has to
get rid of the organelles and DNA inside of
it?
But if we track the origin of these cells,
we get a more complicated picture of what
they mean to us and to our bodies, and even
to our own identity.
Our blood is a soup made up of cells swimming
around in water, salts and proteins.
There are platelets, tiny fragments of cells
that help clot our blood when a vessel breaks.
Then there are white blood cells, which help
protect our body from infection.
But the cells that are the most prevalent
in our blood are red blood cells.
They’re pigmented red by hemoglobin, which
helps the cells transport oxygen to our tissues
and organs, and then transports carbon dioxide
back to the lungs.
The blood you’re seeing now came from James,
our master of microscopes, who had just been
scratched by his cats.
So you can see the red blood cells that came
from the wound, along with the white blood cells.
And to better see those white blood cells,
James added something else to his slide:
spit.
That spit carried bacteria, fresh targets
for the white blood cells.
In our bodies, white blood cells have a very
specific job:
they decide what belongs there, and what does
not.
They seek out molecular markers on bacteria
and other microbes that have become familiar
to our bodies over ages of evolution.
There are different types of white blood cells,
and they vary in the types of organisms they
look for and how they deal with them.
But our favorites might be the white blood
cells that, like the one in the middle of
our screen here, consume their target.
Immunity is often described in war-like terms,
but I like to think of it as something else:
identity.
In effect, the white blood cells are part
of an elaborate mechanism that decides what
is our body, and what is not.
They shape our identity from within, like
a bouncer who decides on the vibe of a nightclub
based on who they let pass.
But bouncers occasionally make mistakes, and
so do white blood cells.
The consequences for white blood cells are
usually more dire, especially if they begin
to turn on us and attack our own bodies, leading
to autoimmune disorders.
Their task of deciding what belongs to us
and what doesn’t is a precarious one,
a task that still requires outside input as
we attempt to shape their responses with
medication or treatment.
In comparison, the tasks of red blood cells
are much more straightforward.
They carry oxygen and carbon dioxide throughout
our body.
But despite their very different lives, the
origins of platelets, red blood cells, and
white blood cells have a significant overlap.
They are all—
with the exception of a few white blood cells—
made in the bone marrow, where they start
as myeloid stem cells.
We describe stem cells as young and immature,
but what we really mean is that they have potential—
the potential to take on one of a number of
identities once they begin maturing.
As the cells divide, signals that describe
what the body needs shape what they become.
If we are low on oxygen, the bone marrow makes
red blood cells.
If we're sick, it makes white blood cells.
And these identities require distinct processes
to make them possible.
For example, to make themselves capable of
holding more oxygen, red blood cells get rid
of their nucleus and other organelles as they
mature, expelling them for white blood cells
called macrophages to clear up.
Consider that a healthy human adult is producing
2 million red blood cells every second.
Now imagine 2 million nuclei being spat out
throughout your body.
And it falls on our macrophages to clear them
out, to ensure that these bits of us that
were definitely once us, now no longer are.
That simplification makes the red blood cells
so capable at their singular task.
But what if that wasn’t their only job?
What if they could do more?
Well, they might.
Scientists recently reported finding evidence
that red blood cells might work alongside
white blood cells and the rest of our immune
system, using receptors to find signs of infection
or tissue damage, and to signal that to the
rest of the immune system so it can act.
They may even sacrifice themselves to macrophages
to trigger the alarm.
This work is relatively new though, and there
is still a lot to learn about the role red
blood cells play in immunity.
And the more we learn about blood, the more
malleable our metaphors and the more complicated
the interplay between identity and immunity
become.
But of course, identity is dynamic.
How can it not be, when it flows through our
veins?
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The names on the screen are our Patreon patrons,
these are the people who have decided to directly
support this channel over at patreon.com/journeytomicro,
so we always want to take this time at the
end of our videos to thank them for their
support.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam & Germs on Instagram and TikTok.
And you can also find Journey to the Microcosmos
on TikTok now if you want some Micro Microcosmos
a couple times a week, and if you want to
see more from us here on YouTube, there is
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.